[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Applaudissements]
bye
bonjour mec
pourquoi
[ __ ] dis moi
[Musique]
alors
wow [
Musique]
les gens disent que mon père ressemble au
critique gastronomique de ratatouille
je ne ressemble pas bien à ce mec  nous
allons te transformer en lui
aujourd'hui
d'accord enfilons des
vêtements appropriés je dois encore me changer tout de suite
lissons les cheveux en arrière je déteste
cette
belle ne me touche pas
le temps pour le maquillage absolument pas beau
maintenant mets le  lunettes sur nous n'avons pas besoin du
verre révélation finale
oh
mon dieu fais le visage je ne veux pas faire
le visage fais le visage
[Musique]
toi